hey interesting voicemail but today our
voicemail number is two one nine two
david p here's someone who thinks that
pat might be making a power play to take
over as host of the david pakman show
it's quite a theory take a listen to
this
yeah they with your boy Patrick for
there he might just be superseded me on
your own show I just wanted to warn you
about that packed all right well you
have a good day there David thank you
appreciate that people used to suggest
this
when Lewis was producer they would say
why can't you make Lewis the host of the
show that will it wouldn't really be the
David Pakman show anymore you know it's
no it's like a confusing thing but I
know what you're talking about wink wink
I know about the powerplay you're
talking about that pat is making teach I
thought on apparently he's caught he
knows what's going on and I know that
you've been playing coy about it Pat but
clearly it's not fooling everybody
because this guy has picked up on it I
mean some people think that I would have
the ability to have a show of my own
I really don't possess those talents I
mean I'm much better over here pushing
my button and chiming in every now and
then I can't do what you do
pushing buttons literally and
figuratively I would say thank you
alright so anyway we will see if Pat I'm
going to do what I can I'm going to try
to stage a resurgence in Frank Underwood
type in a manner reminiscent of Frank
Underwood to try to regain control of
the David Pakman show and we'll see if
that succeeds we've got a tremendous
bonus show for you today folks I mean
it's it's the best trust me people are
telling me this day in and day out david
pakman.com slash membership is how you
sign up and get instant access to that
bonus show and i look forward to
speaking to you then